this is one of the most badass female
characters in shonen
of all time kugisaki novara has a
violent fighting style
is extremely expressive with her
emotions and
awesomely demonstrates that as a girl
you can be both beautiful
and strong at the same time as the only
female first year in a team with two
guys
it's anything but a surprise that many
people have compared kugisaki with a
character that she admittedly shares
quite a lot of these characteristics
with
sakura from naruto however while sakura
in many ways failed to become the strong
female role model that many wanted her
to be
with nobara akutami managed to create an
awesome female character that firmly
stands side by side with itadori and
megumi is
incredibly strong willed and is not
merely reduced to being a love interest
but
in contrary is probably the most
hard-boiled member of the trio
in other words kugisaki is what sakura
was
supposed to be a strong female character
that stands on equal ground with the two
male leads
this is accentuated by the fact that
kugisaki just like gojo
is extremely self-centered and power
oriented and she also actually shares a
quite similar character arc to her
sensei as well
so what exactly is nubara's role in the
story
how strong is she really why do maki and
mai have such an impact on her
and what is her major flaw as a
character
this is the story of kugisaki nobody
despite being part of the main trio in
the story has
not really been assigned a proper
purpose in the story yet something that
akutami does surprisingly often with
characters he introduces
in many cases their role in the story
only becomes clear
much much later or in some cases in true
togashi fashion
the character simply remains a malleable
wild card
now since this is an anime only analysis
i won't give any examples but the manga
readers amongst you will know who i talk
about
long story short novara's role in due to
kaisen both in the manga and the anime
is quite unclear she has escaped the
pitiful fate of being a mere love
interest to the main character
and since fushigoro and itadori have an
unusually
positive relationship also doesn't have
to play the role of moderator
no fighting right
no fighting no [ __ ] farting now
fighting
no [ __ ] fighting
good she's not someone with a grand goal
that we can follow like maki or
someone driven by intense emotions like
yuji or megomi in other words
akutami still keeps kogisaki's deeper
role in the story hidden
that as a part of the main trio she will
without any doubt get at some point
while at the same time giving her an
absolutely
fantastic character arc and more and
more moments in the story to shine so
first
you know what's up let's take a closer
look at her character arc
and her powers
i would argue that kugisaki just like
fushigoro is actually
already plenty strong even in the
beginning of the story and
just like fushigoro and itadori nobara
has also a very
interesting relation with death itadori
is scared of death but is
more than prepared to die to save
someone else fushigoro
generally seems to be too eager to
sacrifice himself whenever he gets the
chance
and nobara definitely doesn't want to
die either but
also isn't particularly scared of death
basically she doesn't mind injuring
herself or even dying as long as she can
pay her opponent back for it enough and
very fittingly i feel her curse
technique allows her to use nails and a
straw doll to attack the opponent from
the distance
inflicting pain and damage she can also
shoot the nails from a distance and thus
influence the environment around her as
well now as a very self-righteous person
nobody doesn't like it when good people
get hurt just like yuji
same as megumi but when she sees herself
in the right she has absolutely no
problem at all
punishing who she thinks is a bad
personality
now the very first thing that becomes
very very obvious to
anyone who encounters nobody for the
very first time is her
incredibly strong and straightforward
personality
quite in the manner of many males male
shonen characters she wears her
feelings and thoughts right there on her
sleeve when she's pissed
she says so
when she thinks something's cute she
says so
and when she's grateful she says so as
well
this straightforwardness is both a
strength and a weakness
and the best scene to illustrate this
central trait of a character
is this one right here
you see the irony here is not only that
nobody has an attack called
sympathy where she inflicts pain on
herself and her opponent
it's that she has close to no sympathy
or empathy in the first place
which in a pretty messed up way is
absolutely hilarious when you think
about it
ironic now while both itadori and megomi
suffer
heavily under the deep feelings of
empathy that they feel for others
it's the girl of the group that suffers
from not having
enough of it what a nice twist to spell
it out really quickly here
basically whenever kugisaki ends up in a
situation that requires her to
understand and relate to the feelings of
another person
she wally and often violently rejects
them
[Music]
to understand why that is let's look at
how nobara approaches the central moral
question of the story what makes a good
life
worth living while both itadori and
fushigoro make this about others
kukisaki much like gojo makes it
mostly about herself for her living a
good life means being
able to express herself freely do what
she likes and spend time with the few
people
she sees as worthy now as always i'm not
necessarily saying that one is better
or more appropriate than the other
juicer kaisen kind of makes it a point
that
most of these characters have valid and
understandable approaches to life and
for nobara escaping the village she grew
up in and moving to tokyo
ended up being her big goal which was
the reason she became a sorcerer in the
first place
thus other than yuji or megomi she has
already
reached her goal and as a result her
desire has now shifted from getting to
tokyo to preserving the life she has
wished for and has now gained
and the way she approaches it is pretty
much the same as
gojol strength when you're strong you
can shape the world around you
do what you want and keep those safe
that matter
noboda thus constantly balances two
personas
her girly feminine side that is
incredibly important to her
as well as being a strong sorcerer and
woman this is
wonderfully symbolized i think by her
weapon a hammer with a pink heart on it
now this duality of her character that i
personally find incredibly cool and well
executed
is explored in great detail during her
fight with
momo
umo holds the position that women in the
g2 world have to be
perfect in order to have a place in
society perfect
of course in the most conservative and
rigid sense of the term
now i think you'll agree that kugisaki
standing up against this idea is a very
important and
impressive move yes women can be both
strong and beautiful and you shouldn't
let your life be determined by what
society says
life isn't a job and you should be able
to be who you are now the thing that
nobody doesn't consider however
is why momo thinks so in the first place
momo has experienced all the unfairness
and harsh expectations that her and the
women around her have faced in the juju
to society
she didn't come up with that view by
herself it's the conclusion she has
drawn personally
from all the suffering and struggle
associated with being a female sorcerer
but
nobody doesn't get that no not only
doesn't she get it
she doesn't want to get it when momo
tries to explain her thoughts
this is her actual reaction to that
[Music]
not having any empathy is the major
flaw of her character just like gojo
kugisaki is
extremely convinced of herself and her
worldview while most other characters
like itadori or nanami for instance
don't have a lot of self-worth and are
constantly doubtful about their own
actions and decisions
she sees herself as 100 righteous
and 100 correct and i think that that is
extremely toxic because we know that
nobody hates
nothing more than people being judgy and
full of prejudice
as happened with her childhood friend
saudi and yet there is
almost no other character injured to
kaisen that is as
close-minded as her the first time we
meet her the very first thing she does
is impose herself on a modeling
recruiter
which is especially funny because they
are seen as pretty creepy and pushy
themselves in tokyo sonobara
immediately leaves a strong impression
by creeping out the creep
establishing her power and presence then
she proceeds to judge
both megumi and yuji within the very
first
10 seconds of meeting them
and she does so with everyone and that's
really sad because even though she
really wants to understand people
she doesn't want to actually listen to
what people have to say
and learn who they actually are and so
this becomes especially clear in her
relationship with maki
and mai just like us viewers the first
impression nobody gets is that maki
is cool confident and reliable while mai
seems to be cold manipulative and
hateful in her own view
maki is the good twin and mai is the
evil twin kugisaki respects maki for her
appearance as a strong woman
and takes her as a role model mai
meanwhile is
evil for taunting her sister for not
having any powers
and once again she thinks she's
absolutely in the right because she's
defending her friend maki that she likes
against a person that she dislikes and
so once again she fails to understand
that
both maki and mai are their own
individual people with their own
individual problems mai never wanted to
become a sorcerer in the first place
but simply wanted to have her sister the
only
real family she ever had by her side
and that sister left her behind to defy
their family
as we learn mai simply wants attention
from maki now don't get me wrong maki of
course has her own struggles and
chose her own path but in the end she
was the one who hurt mai
not the other way around
and someone else tries to explain it to
nobody but
she tells momo to shut up
and so in the end while she's in the
right when it comes to being a woman
and thus wins against momo she fails to
emphasize with mai
and ultimately loses the battle
why is she that way now even in the
manga we know surprisingly little about
nobody's past and how she grew up
we do know however that she always had a
tendency to close herself
off to others no doubt to shield herself
when i say that nobody doesn't feel
empathy i don't mean that she
can't but that she actively won't since
it makes her vulnerable
i think she's very well aware of her own
emotions and at her core
nobara just like gojo really
really cares so much in fact that in the
world of jiu-jitsu where friends can be
killed any moment
she tries to protect herself from
experiencing
that same pain to prove that point
consider the time that we saw how she
reacted to saudi leaving town
almost as if she had passed away
the twist on her relationship with saudi
was basically that this was just a
normal girl that
nobody had a close relationship with and
thus put her up on a pedestal and
similarly we also know that both her
and megumi were actually deeply hurt by
itadori
apparently passing away as well
so in the end her egocentric and
unempathetic approach to life
aren't that surprising what nobody needs
to learn then
is to let her bury us down and just be
more open around other people
listening to what they have to say and
trusting that they're not going to stump
all over her feelings she can remain a
strong independent woman while at the
same time forming
real relationships and you can already
see this happening as well compare how
nobara acts in her first mission with
yuji where she tries to do a solo run
[Music]
with the cursed womb where she
absolutely
seamlessly fights in tandem with itadori
[Music]
character developments this is just an
absolutely
exciting and fun female character and i
can't wait to see what role she will be
playing in the future of the story now
while kugisaki is defined by speaking
her mind
this guy here is known for speaking his
favorite onigiri ingredients
and yet he's one of the most interesting
and popular characters in the story
with one of the most fascinating powers
so make sure to watch inumaki's video by
clicking right
here thanks for watching peace